[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Chris Mannix I want
Mannix to take a Victory lap and
rightfully so he covered yesterday's
game seven Sixers in the Celtics we'll
talk about that but it was about six
weeks ago I think maybe longer than that
when you said the Lakers Lakers going to
the NBA finals
um congratulations there Chris
it must be like chewing glass for you
Dan to say manix take a Victory lap but
it so rarely happens on the show well no
no this is the first time that's why I
don't know what chewing glass tastes
like until now
I have never experienced that before
with you just just wait till like the
Spaniards win an Olympic oh like that's
that's gonna be big you're the you know
Susan Lucci of NBA predictions like
you're gonna eventually get one right
you got it right and congratulations but
what did you mean I got longevity I got
longevity then what did you see though
six weeks ago or two months ago with
this team
it's what exactly what you say it's what
you saw right and after the trade
deadline you saw a team that had pieces
that fit you saw a team that had no
shooting at a bunch of guys that could
shoot you saw a team that didn't play
defense at a bunch of guys that could
play defense and most importantly you
saw after late January Anthony Davis
come back and looked like all NBA level
Anthony Davis I mean he missed three
games from the time he came back from
injury to the end of the regular season
in all three games were because of
back-to-back situations where the team
held him out so when I wrote what I
wrote in late March I had seen enough
like I had seen enough toughness out of
Anthony Davis to believe that we
shouldn't be overly concerned about him
getting hurt having to miss significant
time in the playoffs and you you pair
that with LeBron James even at 38 is
still one of the most dominant playoff
forces that you can find in the NBA it
just was hard for me to find a reason to
pick against them all right let's look
at the teams that bowed out the Warriors
Steve Kerr said that uh he didn't have a
championship caliber team when do you
think he realized that
probably early in the season when it
became clear that the young players that
Golden State expected to step in and
play a significant role weren't capable
of it whether it's Jonathan kaminga or
Moses Moody I mean you remember this is
a team that over the last few years in
addition to their core four they have
had guys like Andre Iguodala or Otto
Porter or Gary Payton II who have been
able to step in and play significant
roles for this team uh for financial
reasons they went into this season uh
without one of those guys Iguodala was
there but he got hurt and like he's been
kind of a fraction of his former self
for some time more of a player coach at
this point and
they just did those young guys weren't
able to fill the role they moved off
James Wiseman kaminga didn't play a
meaningful minute in the postseason
Moody wasn't impactful and these were
things I'm pretty sure Steve Kerr
recognized early on were going to be a
problem with the Warriors
why did Monty Williams get fired
my understanding is that this was a Matt
ishbia production
um
for I don't know why but for whatever
reason Matt ishby had never really
connected with Monty Williams and I
think not only that Phoenix got
eliminated in the second round was a
factor the fact they got eviscerated for
the second time in his many years on
their home floor was a factor um you
know I've talked to a lot of people
around the league about this most people
feel like it was a knee-jerk reaction
but there are some people I've talked to
that you know point to the fact that
maybe Monty Williams had kind of maxed
out with this roster he he obviously
wasn't connecting anymore with DeAndre
ayton and if they want to bring him back
and they may not have a choice but to
bring him back salvaging that may mean
uh replacing the coach and yeah I mean
look the results are what they are you
got beat twice badly on your home floor
in an elimination game in the second
round it's really hard for any coach to
survive that
the Knicks I feel like are in no man's
land it feels like they're a second
round team
they're not threatening
um they they do have talent but I don't
know like they they're missing something
I don't know if Josh Hartz is starting
guard in the NBA with Brunson uh do they
want Julius Randle back RJ Barrett
quietly has played well Obi toppen was a
no-show
but what do the Knicks do to go maybe to
that next or at least attempt to go to
the next level they've got to find that
second option
um they have I think a really solid
first option in Jalen Brunson who I
think has proven you know last year in
the postseason and this year all season
he can be that guy that can lead a team
in the playoffs I think they have a
really solid third option in RJ Barrett
who needs to be more consistent needs to
be more efficient but if you're talking
about him as a third option that's
pretty good to have Julius Randle can't
be the second option he can't look he's
shown in two of the last three years
that in the playoffs when defenses can
really key on him and throw different
things at him he doesn't have a counter
to it he's not an efficient jump shooter
he's overly Reliant at times on the
three-point shot when he's really not a
three-point shooter look the Knicks have
a lot of assets like they didn't make
the trade for Donovan Mitchell so they
kept their powder dry they kept their
cache of draft picks intact they've got
some decent young player they can shop
their priority this off season is
finding that number two guy to fit
between Brunson and RJ Barrett if they
find that guy
they can be you know a contending team
but this team has currently constituted
you just saw their ceiling they are a
second round team and that's it Chris
Mannix from Sports Illustrated senior
writer what do you hear when you hear
joellenbid say this
I I got to be better and I will be
better that's what I'm focused on you
can't win Alone
um I can't win alone I can't me and
James we just can't win alone you know
that's why basketball is played 505 so
you know we just need everybody to just
you know try to keep finding ways to get
better and uh you know we'll be fine
what do you hear
well look I I was at that press
conference that embiid said that
yesterday and In fairness to embiid I
counted five times before and after he
made that statement that he put it on
himself he said losses belong to the
quote-unquote best player put it all on
me so he did take responsibility for
this loss as he should because he was
Dreadful in the second half of this game
I don't think he's wrong that this team
needs to make some changes to get to the
next level
um the biggest question is really James
Harden right now Dan like that to me
looms large over this organization if
James Harden opts out of his contract
I don't know how the Philadelphia 76ers
pay him I don't I don't know how you can
justify giving James Harden a three or a
four year contract at 35 or 40 million
dollars per year because the second you
sign him to that contract it becomes the
most untradable contract in the NBA you
can't move off it you are stuck with it
and James Harden Dan showed him this
series he had 45 in game one he had 42
in game four he can still pick a team up
on his back and carry them but game six
and seven were awful he shot what 28 or
29 in game seven it was 25 in game six
if you're Philadelphia as tough as it
would be to just cut ties with James
Harden you got to do it because you've
got Tyrese Max see who I think is going
to go to another level next year and
might be better off with more
play-making responsibilities with harden
off the roster you've got embiid who's
only going to be 30. I think they can
get something for the contract of Tobias
Harris in a trade they've got to make a
tough call on James Harden and Daryl
Mori who's got a lot of loyalty to James
Harden for all those years in Houston he
has got to make the tough choice and say
look James we appreciate what you've
done but we can't make that type of
financial commitment to you with this
team that we have how would you explain
Jason Tatum's last five quarters
awesome I mean that's that's really what
it is and and I've had kind of a a
bird's eye view at the development of
Jayson Tatum over the last few years and
every year it seems like he adds
something to his game every year his
confidence goes to another level every
year his game goes to another level all
season long Dan this was largely the guy
that you saw a top five MVP player all
NBA first team and he is someone that
has that Kobe bryant-like irrational
confidence you saw it in game six where
he's terrible for three and a half
quarters but he doesn't let that affect
him he doesn't let that phase him and he
has the great final four or five minutes
of game six to carry them through look
all over the last couple of days the
only thing people in Jason Tatum's Camp
were telling him were just relaxed man
he was putting so much pressure on
himself to succeed in these first
quarters and he was terrible in the last
few games in the first uh of fourth
quarter he relaxed in game seven he took
the ball to the basket early on and once
he got got it rolling he is a really
difficult player to stop he is one of
the top two or three best scorers right
now in the NBA
what does the NBA do with John morent
that's a good question
um I can tell you from talking to you
know people in and around the league
that there is a palpable frustration
with John Morant right now I mean it's
likely that the NBA Dan believes they
did John Miranda favor last time around
they showed compassion for John Moran
last time around he said he was going
through anxiety issues depression issues
mental health issues he went to the
league office and he apologized face to
face uh to Adam Silver and then less
than two months later yeah he does the
exact same thing the exact same thing I
would expect in while this will not be a
swift process because there's no reason
to to move quickly on it this will be a
severe punishment
um I think the NBA felt like you know
they showed they it like it was like the
carrot last time that they gave John
Moran now I think the NBA is going to
show him the stick uh there's just
everybody I've talked to there's been a
lot of frustration with how this whole
thing played out how the league probably
feels like they got played by John
Morant to a degree I would expect this
to be a significant suspension going
into next season I know that people like
to dismiss the bubble title for LeBron
but here we are with the same four teams
that were in the bubble a couple of
years ago here
how does it play out
I still like the Lakers because I'm not
backing off that pick though Nicole
jokic I mean where are the people I
don't hear them where are the people
that said Nicole jokic is not a
postseason player he's been great from
start to finish in this postseason but I
think the Lakers experience and the fact
that these games are probably going to
be pretty close I like LeBron and A.D in
those types of situations
I hate to
downplay Miami as I'm about to but I
don't
I just don't think they're on Boston's
level I think Miami had the benefit in
the first round of playing a Bucks team
that was without Giannis for three of
five games they had the benefit in the
second round of playing a deeply flawed
New York Knicks team against Boston a
team that's healthy that's clicking and
likely with Miami without Tyler hero for
the duration of this series I just don't
see how they compete I think the Celtics
win this series in five games I think
it's a lot easier a series than some
people are expecting and I think we get
that match up that Adam Silver will
never admit he really wants but
desperately craves Celtics Lakers back
in the NBA Finals thank you Chris you
got it Dan that's Chris Mannix
occasionally he gets it right
Sports Illustrated senior basketball
writer